nous sommes mercredi matin il est 6
heures je viens de rentrer
d'intervention cette nuit nous avons été
appelés pour un individu qui a tiré sur
la police et qui s'est retranché à son
domicile lorsque je vais prendre attache
avec lui cet homme va me dire qu'il
entend des odeurs son chien est blessé
il ya du sang partout autour de lui et
qu'il s'est fait attaquer par des
parasites
manifestement il est délirant on travail
va consister évidemment à leurs assurés
mais à m'attacher à la partie la plus
cohérente de son discours il vient de me
dire qu'il est blessé alors je vais lui
proposer de lui venir en aide
après plusieurs échanges cet individu a
accepté de se rendre
en réalité il n'a pas de chien il n'est
pas blessé il n'y a aucune trace de sang
dans son appartement et les parasites
auquel il fait allusion sont les
policiers qui ont riposté après qu'il
aurait tiré dessus
cet homme a fait ce que l'on appelle une
bouffée délirante c'est à dire qu'il a
connue de manière momentanée et brutale
un épisode délirant 11 heures du matin
soit à peu près cinq heures plus tard
nous sommes de nouveau appelé pour un
homme qui lui s'est barricadé après
avoir lancé sur la police des bombes
artisanales
la police locale
nous renseigner sur le fait que cet
individu est particulièrement dangereux
et des retranché déjà depuis plusieurs
heures
je comprends que cette situation risque
de durer nous sommes fatigués nous avons
passé une nuit blanche et pourtant il va
falloir que nous ayons la même
disponibilité dès le premier échange cet
individu va donner le ton il va me dire
je vous connais je sais comment on
fonctionne et je connais votre armement
et piéger ma maison j'ai piégé mon
jardin eux disposent de plusieurs armes
à feu à partir de ce moment là les
autorités vont décider de faire évacuer
la totalité du quartier
de nos échanges
régulièrement méfiant il sera à l'affût
de nos moindres faits et gestes il va
être particulièrement menaçant mais
pendant nos conversations je vais me
rendre compte que cet individu est en
train de vivre une situation
particulièrement difficile
je vais rentrer avec lui dans son
histoire et son histoire c'est celle
d'un homme qui a construit sa maison de
ses propres mains et puis pour un
problème de parcelles il s'est engagé
dans un procès qui va durer un peu plus
de vingt ans il va dépenser énormément
d'argent dans des procédures judiciaires
très coûteuse il va perdre son emploi sa
femme va nous quitter il va perdre ce
procès et sa maison va être vendu aux
enchères
je vais l'accompagner dans la difficulté
qu'il a à admettre l'inadmissible pour
lui je vais tenter de construire un
rapport de confiance malgré sa méfiance
ces provocations et ses menaces au bout
de dix heures de conversation
dix heures de négociations les autorités
s'impatiente parce que nous avons des
familles entières qui sont logés dans un
gymnase un de nos chefs de service va
émettre l'hypothèse que cet homme ne va
pas se rendre et la décision est prise
d'aller le chercher au moment où le
groupe d'intervention va se rapprocher
de la maison cet individu va ouvrir le
feu nous allons immédiatement demandé à
reprendre le contact parce que nous
sommes convaincus en tant que
négociateur que le meilleur point
d'entrée pour résoudre cette situation
reste la négociation nous allons
reprendre le contact nous allons
négocier avec lui plusieurs heures que
cet individu va se rendre alors ce fut
une négociation particulièrement longue
à la durée un peu plus de quinze heures
difficiles l'homme est paranoïaque
dangereuse et il nous aura tiré dessus à
plusieurs reprises mais c'est surtout
une négociation particulièrement
sensible elle est nourrie
d'incompréhension de douleurs de colère
de beaucoup de tristesse cette maison
c'est l'histoire de sa vie il ya vécu de
nombreuses années avec sa femme
cette maison c'est tout ce qui lui
restait alors oui nous lui avons donné
du temps dans la négociation pour
comprendre et accepter cet état et faire
le choix de la reddition mais pourquoi
est ce que nous faisons cela au fond
parce que notre métier c'est de sauver
des vies il ne nous appartient pas de
juger notre mission c'est d'obtenir la
résolution pacifique de la crise j'ai
été
pietri au raid pendant un peu plus de 13
ans au cours de mes études de droit je
rêvais de devenir avocate mais au détour
d'un article
j'ai découvert le métier passionnant et
inconnus des négociateurs de crise
criminelle ça a été comme une révélation
et ça faisait surtout écho à ce que je
ressentais à mes valeurs à mon état
d'esprit à ma philosophie
je suis passionné par les rapports
humains et j'aime et je défends l'idée
de justice et d'équité et je reste
persuadé je reste convaincu que le
meilleur point d'entrée pour résoudre
les situations restent la communication
alors à ce moment là je vais totalement
changer de voie et je vais décider de
passer le concours d'officier pour
rentrer au raid
veux et je vais devenir négociatrice
aurait entre le moment où je vais
prendre la décision et le moment où je
vais intégrer l'unité il va se passer à
peu près sept ans ça va pas être simple
il va falloir oser oser parce que
candidater au raid quand on est une
femme
mais ni coutumier ni facile ni même
encouragé je vais voir sortir de ma zone
de confort je vais devoir me dépasser
tant physiquement que psychologiquement
les tests sont difficiles les candidats
nombreux et la préférence masculine est
clairement annoncée
j'aurais tout juste 30 ans en tant que
triste je vais pouvoir mettre en avant
tout l'intérêt d'une solution pacifiées
quand bien même la situation nous paraît
totalement perdus ou inespéré je vais
comprendre que dans cette nécessaire
négociations
il nous faut cheminer avec notre
interlocuteur il nous faut comprendre
notre interlocuteur je vais comprendre
que pour obtenir ce qui est juste je
vais devoir collaborer et je vais devoir
je vais avoir besoin de lui pour y
arriver je vais comprendre que pouvoir
réussir
il va nous falloir nous entendre or bien
maman ça va pas forcément être toujours
très simple je vais devoir aller
chercher au delà des apparences je vais
devoir aller chercher l'humain au delà
de ces actions alors non ça n'a pas
toujours été simple de négocier avec
l'impensable l'impensable c'est ce père
de famille qui va tuer ses enfants parce
que sa femme a demandé le divorce
non ça n'a pas toujours été compris non
plus de négocier ou de laisser
s'exprimer ce terroriste qui vient de
tuer un couple de policiers qui retient
en otage leur petit garçon d'à peine 4
ans
autant je vais apprendre à négocier dans
un cadre normes et l'éthique dans les
négociations c'est ce garde fou qui va
me permettre de fonctionner en toute
objectivité
sans aucun jugement et avec le respect
de l'autre je vais
voir comprendre les actions je vais
devoir comprendre les motivations de mes
interlocuteurs sans les juger sans leur
mentir sans les trahir sans les
manipuler le dépassement de soi dans
cette discipline c'est d'aller chercher
l'humain au delà de ces actes quand bien
même ils nous font rares 80% des
situations de crise se résolve à la
négociation
80 % ce n'est pas le fruit du hasard
mais c'est bien le résultat d'une
méthode qui fonctionne et elles
fonctionnent ces négociations parce
qu'elles sont mises en place au regard
d'une très grande préparation d'un
respect d'un formalisme de l'application
de règles d'observation de fondamentaux
et d'une éthique clair
je vous parle les négociations de crise
criminel parce que ça a été mon métier
pendant toutes ces années mais quand on
y réfléchit
il s'agit exactement de la même sauf la
même chose dans toutes sortes de
négociation je pense notamment aux
négociations commerciales négociation
syndicale aux négociations sociales dès
lors que vous faites le choix de la
négociation vous savez que vous avez
besoin de l'autre partie pour obtenir
quelque chose et qu'est ce que vous
allez faire pour cette négociation
lorsque vous allez là préparez vous
allez penser à vos intérêts les intérêts
que vous devez défendre vous allez
listez vos besoins vous allez lister des
choses sur lesquelles vous pouvez céder
et les choses sur lesquelles vous ne
souhaitez absolument pas transiger et
l'autre partie elle va faire exactement
la même chose et c'est normal au fond
alors dans cette négociation comment est
ce que vous vous allez
vous positionnez est ce que vous faites
le choix de votre parti est d'observer
uniquement votre point de vue et
défendre vos propres intérêts au risque
de vous embarquer dans une négociation
de position vous comprenez que dans
cette négociation l'autre partie a
autant de raisons que vous de vouloir
obtenir ce qui lui semble juste et dans
ce cadre là vous faites le choix de
collaborer pour mettre en place une
solution qui vous convienne à tous les
deux
j'ai rejoint
le secteur
rêver il y a à peu près quatre ans et
juste avant ça je vais vous parler d'une
autre affaire qui me revient à l'esprit
lorsque il ya quelques années nous avons
été appelés pour un forcené qui s'était
retranché après s'être disputé avec sa
femme lorsque l'on arriveront sur place
les la police locale nous met à
disposition les témoins et les voisins
et lorsque nous prenons contact avec
avec ces témoins
d'accord pour nous dire que l'homme qui
viennent se retrancher est une personne
absolument odieuses colérique violente
quelqu'un qui dit quasiment jamais
bonjour qu'il ne voit quasiment jamais
mais quand ils entendent très souvent
les cris lorsque nous allons entendre sa
femme celle ci va nous dire qu'elle a
réussi à s'échapper de l'appartement
parce que son mari venait de menacer de
la suite
alors forcément quand vous entendez ces
informations vous faites une
représentation de l'individu que vous
allez avoir en face de vous et c'est
normal sauf qu'en tant que négociateur
nous essayons d'être le plus en
ouverture possible de ne pas juger notre
interlocuteur indépendamment de qui les
indépendamment du contexte nous devons
être en ouverture donc nous allons
chercher chez l'autre les informations
qu'il nous manque pour ne pas prendre le
risque de s'enfermer dans un chemin qui
ne laisserait aucune place à notre
interlocuteur ce jour là lorsque l'on va
prendre contact effectivement va
s'avérer qu'il va être exactement comme
on nous l'a décrit il va nous insulter
il va nous menacer c'est un homme en
colère qui va absolument pas parlé à la
police il va raccrocher au téléphone à
de nombreuses reprises et le négociateur
va insister et au bout d'un certain
temps
cet individu va accepter enfin ce
contact là relie va y avoir de nombreux
échanges pendant plusieurs heures où il
va ventilé c'est à dire qu'il va laisser
s'exprimer plusieurs émotions et puis
petit à petit le combat se radoucir et
puis il va commencer à parler de sa
situation personnelle il va se mettre à
pleurer
en réalité ce jour là nous allons
comprendre que la victime n'est pas
celle que l'on pensait que le bourreau
n'est pas celui qu'on prend en réalité
la victime de ces violences c'est cet
homme et ce soir là il s'est retranché
parce qu'il avait l'intention de se
suicider pour échapper à la violence
qu'ils enduraient depuis des années et à
la honte qu'il ressentait
si nous étions passés à côté des
fondamentaux de la négociation être en
ouverture voir les choses d'un oeil neuf
aller chercher l'information chez
l'individu comprendre au delà de ce qui
est exprimé ne pas juger indépendamment
de du contexte ou de la personne nous
serions passés à côté de cet homme et de
sa réalité
comme je vous le disais j'ai rejoint le
privé il est à peu près quatre ans l'une
de mes activités consistent à
accompagner des collaborateurs des
managers des dirigeants sur des
problématiques de négociations mais sur
des problématiques également de
relations interpersonnelles
lorsque l'on aborde les cas de
négociations c'est assez communément
admis aujourd'hui que il faut absolument
qu'on arrive à préserver une relation
future alors nous imaginons et nous nous
mettons en place nous pensons la
négociation de manière globale
ce que l'on va retenir d'une négociation
c'est pas tant ce que vous avez obtenu
c'est la manière dont vous l'avez obtenu
lorsque l'on aborde les questions de
relations interpersonnelles c'est
parfois un peu plus compliqué de réussir
à faire un pas de côté pour comprendre
la situation
comprendre ce qu'il se passe dans notre
interaction pourquoi est-ce que j'ai du
mal interagir avec cette personne
pourquoi est-ce que son comportement me
dérange
qu'est ce que je fais moins en réaction
pour arranger ça comment moi je peux
m'adapter
finalement comment je peux évoluer dans
cette relation pour que nous puissions
enfin interagir ensemble parce que c'est
nécessaire
j'ai appris énormément de choses au sein
du rpt
dans toutes ces années ce que j'ai
retenu c'est que la technique n'était
efficace et pertinente que si elle vient
servir un état que c'est bien servir une
posture que c'est bien servir un savoir
être dans toutes les négociations quelle
qu'elle soit ce que je retiens et que je
mets en application
c'est le fait d'aborder ces situations
de manière neutre et impartiale parce
que ça me permet d'être le plus en
ouverture possible que de savoir gérer
mes émotions ça me permet de me des
centres et ça me permet d'avoir du recul
et ne pas me laisser submerger avoir de
l'empathie c'est un puissant levier pour
comprendre mes interlocuteurs je garde
ça toujours à l'esprit parce que j'ai
conscience que si j'accepte l'acte de
négocier c'est qu'à priori je fais le
choix de vouloir résoudre par la
communication nos différents où nos
conflits
je
[Applaudissements]